venezuela tiene un nuevo tribunal
supremo de justicia con once magistrados
ratificados gladys gutiérrez fue
juramentada como presidenta un cargo que
ya ocupó entre 2013 y 2017 subimos esta
nueva nuevamente esta responsabilidad
animado por el sentir del pueblo que
confía en el poder judicial para obtener
la tutela de los derechos consagrados en
la constitución la designación se
produce un día después de que la
asamblea nacional de mayoría oficialista
eligiera los 20 magistrados de una lista
de 400 candidatos como parte de la
llamada revolución judicial anunciada
por el presidente nicolás maduro
muy bien
gutiérrez se encuentra en la lista de
funcionarios oficialistas sancionados
por eeuu por su participación en
decisiones como las sentencias que
socavaron las funciones de la asamblea
nacional electa en 2015 el líder
opositor reconocido por más de 60 países
como presidente interino juan guaidó
rechazó la elección del nuevo tsj que a
su juicio busca proteger a violadores de
derechos humanos bajo la fachada de una
renovación del sistema judicial esta
dirigente opositora teme que el gobierno
de maduro pretenda desmontar las
investigaciones de la corte penal
internacional sobre crímenes de lesa
humanidad en venezuela están contactando
a las víctimas de crímenes de lesa
humanidad y les bible les piden que
cierren los casos para disminuir el
número de casos y así también decirle a
la corte que se está haciendo justicia
en venezuela otro sector de la oposición
con representación en la asamblea
nacional se declaró satisfecho con las
nuevas designaciones